m
françois françois fecteau la question tu
as tu fait partie des clubs sportifs
maintenant oui mais non enfin c'est à
dire je voudrais former une équipe avec
toi avec moi ouais et due forme une
équipe de quoi je voudrais faire une
équipe à la pétanque avec ça ouais avec
ça mais c'est pas une boule de pétanque
kazim est un ânon mais ça c'est là si le
bouchon à parce que ça c'est le bouchon
d'un bouchon de pétanque c'est tout
petit tient d'y avoir un joli
julie est ce que par hasard tu aurais un
bouchon de pétanque pour montrer casimir
bien sûr mais il faut d'abord que
j'arrive à trouver l'endroit où je
l'aimé parce que il ya tellement de
choses là dedans
peut-être tu vas casimir rôle un bouchon
de pétanque comme ça tout petit et c'est
en voir à oui bon ben alors pas je me
suis trompé de sport
je sais comment on y joue mais j'ai
oublié le nom est tu as oublié le nom
les offres venez voir pierre portant
beau show joly merci jean voir ici tu
peux faire des bulles évidemment que tu
peux faire des bulles frédéric mais doit
pas essayer
voilà ce qui se passe casimir à oublier
le sport dont il fait partie alors
chacun notre tour on va ferrer mines
vous êtes d'accord oui dans l'antre de
répit enfin il pisse froid et puis
principal de sifflet
si c'est pas super sport voilà c'est ça
la rend alors qu'ils commencent eric
eric tu vas certainement grâce par
exemple à je vais pas y arriver et nous
on cherche
vas-y eric rihs continue
c'est la boxe c'est ça bon alors un
autre maintenant dominique mais vous le
faites c'est sur mon dos va vous
continuez un petit vin à nos serres où
elle et dominique vas-y tu te mets là
bas allez voilà un c'est une championne
dominicaine basket ball stéphane qui
joue au basket
dominique non pas du droit parce que
allez tu vas en ferrain stéphane aller
l'asile attali ce faire les différents
types et sky et moon
c'est ça bon qui en fait un maintenant
nathalie allait naître tu vois tout à
l'heure tout allait continuer un petit
peu mais c'est le tennis et continuer
ainsi que m voilà qui joue au tennis
nathalie non tu devras et patrick
legrand faisait ça c'est un sportif
patrick un zébu le jeu 61e manger lui
puis ce 74e continue oui alors que ce
s'est fait fait le nouveau film titeuf
peut-être servir à mieux
voilà là on va beaucoup mieux alors
qu'est ce que c'est
non cherchons quasi néant
je n'ai pas trouvé encore atteint c'est
le javelot caezar rallier toulouse en
fait un autre
ah oui il y en a d'autres alors vas-y
aller
qu'est-ce que ça casimir jeu ouais si
j'optais jaune c'est pas du karaté alors
encore un petit peu à peu casimir
regarde bien il ya aussi un ballon la du
bois mais c'est par la même forme que
celui là alors laurent c'est du rugby
très bien moi qui m'en faut un
maintenant qu'ils ont fait invasif
amérique face à nokia
félix genty hassan ou au comptoir à
temps oui l'iphone est et bâle un titre
dans un petit trou et avec quoi lol mais
l'oreille c'est tout et le golf tessa
bon est ce qu'on en a encore un laurence
aller laurence à toi la regarde bien
et comment dufresne faut arrêter ce qui
en chasse elle ajouté c'est ça oui c'est
le ski bon laurent tu vas nous faire
aimer
allez vas-y vas-y recommence mais chez
nous on recommencera comme marie très
bien
qu'est ce que c'est vous avez trouvé
chez le cheval c'est par un sport cheval
un jockey un jeune lyonnais
qu'est ce que c'est alors leur chemin du
cheval ont bon bah c'est un petit peu
c'est presque c'est une équipe très
jeune et ça fait du cheval 1 c'était
équitation alors que les émirs parmi
tous ces supports est ce que tu a
reconnu le tir
non non je ne comprends pas non tu
comprends pas non je crois qu'il reste
plus que le football
ouais c'est ce que la terre qui va
dominer toi même bref c'est un naze mais
dont la whey allez vas-y casimir
alors tu sais
c'est ça le sport je cherchais sa
formidable à pau au casimir